if you want to have success on YouTube
making videos and have people really
relate to them and showcase yourself as
an expert then you have to believe
passionately in what you're talking
about and share things that are
important to you hi I'm Evan Carmichael
and I believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help so today i'm answering a
question from one of my readers nick who
wrote in to say he was asked about my
videos hi of them I'm in the process of
improving my video communications and I
think yours are really good what's the
secret other than your incredible talent
Thank You Nick and wrote in with
specific questions that I'm going to get
into so first one is how did you get so
good was a natural talent lots of
practice did you get coach did you do
training I don't think I'm particularly
good at it I've done some speaking
before so that may have helped a little
bit but i don't think i have natural
talent for it it did take a lot of
practice if you go back and look at my
earlier videos they were really bad some
of them i'm so embarrassed about that i
want to take down but people keep
watching them and leaving comments on
them that are positive so i keep them up
but i really want to take them down
anyway so it has taken a lot of practice
i have a couple hundred videos now up on
youtube and i think the biggest thing
with practice is just getting used to
talking to the camera I found when I was
getting started I was a little nervous
when i pressed record I was fine before
it sounded great but then you stand in
front of the camera you look right into
it and you press record and I don't know
I got shaky my heart was beating so it
sweating a little bit so as you do more
of those it gets easier I also found
that when people were around me watching
or even just working on their own thing
I got more nervous and I didn't create a
good quality video so as you do more you
do get more comfortable front of the
camera so I think that's helped I also
did trying to model success something
obviously I believe in modeling success
just like you're doing where you're
watching my videos and saying hey I like
what everyone's doing I'm going to try
to model that I did the same thing when
I was starting and looked at other
channels that I liked and tried to model
what they were doing and still do now I
still try to see you know what pieces I
could pull from what other people are
doing and apply it to my own videos as
well and then third I work with an agent
in New York and they have given me some
feedback and tips on my videos and I try
to apply those
as well but the most important thing
from all of that is really you have to
strongly believe in the message of each
video it's so important and I think in
my earlier videos I was passionate about
them but I didn't raise the stakes
enough I didn't make it important enough
and what I try to think about now is
when somebody asked me a question that
my answer can help make the difference
between them giving up or keep on going
I have to convince them to follow the
advice I have to make it important for
them and so you should try to apply that
to your videos as well you have great
advice but if you deliver it in a blend
or boring way or it sounds like you're
reading something it's not going to hit
them you know you could say the same
thing with a lot of excitement and
importance and urgency or really boring
and I'm trying to memorize my script and
it doesn't come out very cleanly and
that'll make all the difference so I try
to make an important I try to think of
that person and having an impact on them
and that one video I have that one
chance every time I do a video to be
able to have an impact on that one
person's life and if they don't change
part of that is on me that's my
responsibility because I didn't do
enough to really convince them through
the video that this is the correct path
that they should take so that's helped a
lot second question when you talk to the
camera do you have a script behind the
camera I never use a script I find that
if you're trying to memorize something
or if you're trying to read something
people can tell great you see people
looking off to the side like this or
trying to read in and and see what the
words are so they say it exactly right
the problem is is always boring you
never say things with the right amount
of passion if you're reading it off a
script and it's way more important to
get your point across it's way more
important to have the feeling and energy
and passion to convince somebody that
what you're saying is really the path
they should take
that comes not from reading a script
it's not so much what you say it's how
you say it so don't worry about getting
every single word right because it's
going to stress you out neither dad the
beginning to you know I didn't read from
a script but i memorize things and I
tried to get everything out exactly and
we do lots of cuts and takes and it
never looked good so now when a message
comes in i'll look at it on my phone
really quickly i might come up with a
couple points in my head and then i'll
just get in front of the camera and talk
and again try to think about talking to
that person and having an impact with
each video that I make and if I make
mistakes along the way I've already made
a few in this video I just keep rolling
you keep going with it because that's
part of the process of making videos and
I think it makes people think you're
more human and are more willing to
listen to the things that you're saying
what equipment do you use number three
questions so I don't believe in spending
money till I'm making money and so I
didn't want to go out and spend tons of
money on the all the equipment because I
didn't know if it would make money but
also I didn't know if I would stick with
it you know a lot of entrepreneurs get
excited about new projects go buy all
the equipment by tons of inventory for
their new idea and then a couple months
later I get bored of it and move on to
something else and meanwhile you spent
all this money on this equipment that
you're not using so I started off really
simple really dead easy it was with my
own flip camera and if you watch some of
the earlier videos might see if shaking
a little bit very embarrassing but again
people like them the production quality
is really poor the lighting sucks the
audio is really bad and then slowly as i
learned the techniques behind video
production as well as making a little
bit of money I poured it back into the
videos so now i use a sony handycam i
bought it from costco i bought all my
stuff from costco because they have a 90
day return policy compared to other
stores that were seven or 14 so it gives
you the chance to really test out the
products make sure you like it before
you really commit to it sony handycam
the reason why I got it is because it
has an external mic jack so people were
complaining earlier about my videos that
they couldn't hear me properly the audio
quality wasn't great
so needed a camera with an external
microphone and then i went to the sony
store and bought this microphone eighty
or ninety dollars that you just clip in
and it works in there and then the other
thing i use is a tripod just picked it
up from my local camera store and that's
all i use i don't really use much
lighting now i'm doing this video in my
office there's a window in front of me
so I get the light hitting my face and
that's it i use my phone to kind of give
me the clues as to what to talk about
next and that's equipment that I use so
it's still pretty low budget but enough
to get everything going i didn't want
super high production quality as well
because I don't know sometimes that that
makes it look not very authentic so
that's what i'm using right now and last
do you edit the videos so again i don't
like spending money till i'm making
money so at the beginning I learned
everything myself I started with windows
movie maker that comes default with
every you know windows computer that you
buy and then I moved up the Camtasia and
learn how to do the video editing and it
was really poor you know I wasn't great
at it but it was enough to put it up and
get it up on the website and then again
as I started making money I quickly
looked at okay how can i delegate this
because of a look at what I'm doing with
the videos the best use of my time is
getting in front of the camera and doing
more videos and answering questions and
helping people it's not trying to figure
out how to be a video editor because I'm
not really good at it and it's really
not the best use of my time on going so
as soon as I started making money I
quickly found somebody who could edit
and produce and do all the fancy stuff
with my videos again it's not crazy and
we have the intro you know extra a
couple touch-ups you know we're moving
me at the beginning testing the
microphone and all that kind of stuff
you know picking my nose whatever it is
but yeah I started off doing everything
myself and then slowly expanded and
brought on people to help me with it so
that's it hopefully Nick that helped out
good luck with your videos if you want
to send me your first couple that you do
I'd love to be able to take a look at it
and give you some some advice for those
are you watching if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below I
always love seeing those come in
and if you have a comment about this
video or a question for your business I
want to try to help answer it for you
please leave it in the comments section
below it's really one of the best parts
of my day is watching those YouTube
comments come in so thank you and I'll
see you on the next episode
you